mathieu bola reda secrétaire du syndicat
cgt cheminots de versailles bonsoir et
nicolas glières enseignants et membres
des stylos rouges bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être là sur ce plateau d'ayrté
france d'abord monsieur bonne red eye
votre réaction à l usage du 49 3
alors évidemment c'est un mot qui a déjà
été utilisé que je et que j'assume que
je pense c'est un coup d'état
effectivement c'est une action
excessivement brutale et autoritaire
mais qui est dans le droit fil de la
réaction du gouvernement depuis aussi
attendait depuis le début non mais
attendez on a tout eu on a eu les
charges policières sur les piquets on a
eu des la brutalité policière dans les
manifestations on a eu les députés de
l'opposition à qui ont coupé le micro en
commission des lois
on n'a pas du tout écouter ni même le
conseil d'état aujourd'hui le 49-3
j'observe quand même que le même jour le
même jour que le gouvernement annonce
annonce le recours du 49 3 par ailleurs
il pour des motifs dits sanitaire le
prétexte du coronavirus il prétend
interdire les manifestations publiques
de rue au delà de 2 de 5000 personnes
donc en plus il veut empêcher la
population les citoyens de pouvoir
réagir donc je pense que là ce qui est
très important de noter c'est que
jusqu'à présent un impératif social un
impératif économique et social nous
travailleurs de se défendre contre un
projet de loi qui visait à détruire
notre régime de retraite solidaire par
répartition
là aujourd'hui je pense que la
population française se retrouve devant
un impératif démocratique de lutter pour
faire tomber ce projet de loi -
aujourd'hui je vous drapez au delà des
travailleurs l'ensemble des citoyens
l'ensemble des démocrates des gens épris
de liberté de mettre le pied dans la
porte et de dire à bâle l'autoritarisme
du président macro et de sa petite secte
aujourd'hui la république en marche qui
sont les derniers à soutenir ce projet
contre l'avis de tous le monde 70 % des
français la totalité des syndicats
l'ensemble des partis politiques excepté
le sien je pense qu'aujourd'hui il va
falloir qu'il y ait une insurrection des
consciences et qu'elle se manifeste dans
la rue pour faire tomber ce projet dont
on le voit ce soir il ya déjà des
manifestants nombreux devant l'assemblée
nationale justement pour protester
contre le recours aux 49 3 nicolas
glières on s'attendait à ce 49,3
justifié selon la majorité par de
l'obstruction de la part des députés qui
ont déposé des milliers d'amendements
mais c'est assez ce timing aujourd'hui
qui surprend tout le monde sait pas
surprenant du tout aussi attendait comme
vous venez de dire surtout en fait on a
l'habitude de ces procédés ils ont
l'habitude d'utiliser tout ce qui est
légal mais immoral pour écraser la
population là on a vraiment amoureux un
mouvement d'écrasement
tu parlais tout à l'heure de la
répression policière et autres on a des
lycéens qui ont été tabassés des profs
qui ont été menacés intimidés
illégalement par des autorités
politiques recteur ministre sans qu'il
ne leur arrive rien
il ya un moment il va falloir que ces
gens y compris monsieur blanc caire se
retrouve devant au poste devant un
policier
ce sont des justiciables comme les
autres ils n'ont pas à menacer les gens
ils n'ont pas intimidé le gouvernement
nous montre aussi que l'autoritarisme et
à la mode
nous montrons n'est pas la raison
monsieur erdogan pour ces procédés on
attend quoi là en france pour réagir et
49 3 étoiles et n'est pas quelque chose
d' autoritaire puisque ces visages aussi
dans la city morale dans la constitution
immoral ça a beau être légale c'est
immoral le partage des richesses est
complètement inégalement de paris cdg
dans notre pays c'est légal mais c'est
immoral
ce que les français ne comprennent pas
et finalement et on le voit l'opposition
également qui a déposé des motions de
censure
ça fait l'unanimité contre elle un cette
majorité qui a déposé ce 49 3 cet usage
a déjà une course où la vème république
mais la grande nouveauté c'est que c'est
un parlement avec une majorité
finalement sa présidence
après c'est l'utilisation du 49 3 c'est
pas forcément l'esprit qui en avait dans
la conception mais pas sur la question
du fait que ça soit légal oui c'est
légal
la constitution permet aussi au
président de l'écart et l'état de siège
s'il veut l'état d'urgence et de
déployer l'armée dans le pays pourrait
aussi aller à baden baden pour demander
la fidélité des généraux français pour
pour se déployer sur le territoire
national on pourrait aussi arrêté
puisque ce serait légal les citoyens qui
font des manifestations les confiner
chez eux et c'est ce serait légale mais
à un moment donné la question
effectivement de la moralité n'est pas
seulement ça la question de la
légitimité politique celle ci se pose
aujourd'hui on a la majorité des
français qui sont contre les par tous
les partis tous les syndicats c'est à
dire qu'on a aujourd'hui
mais j'entendais monsieur macron qui
chouine est au près dans cette petite
confession la journaliste un peu en
europe en disant oui je traverse et on
traite de dictateurs mais aller voir
ailleurs ce que c'est la dictature
c'est un clan qui impose sa loi
moi je vois ça en fait je vois un tout
petit clan d'ailleurs à la république en
mars qui n'ont cependant toujours n'y
pas grand chose dans le pays
je parle pas seulement des douilles qui
vont se prendre municipal mais qui
effectivement représente assez peu dans
le pays qui défendent des intérêts très
particuliers
même pas ceux de tout le medef à la
limite 1 mais de la grande finance un
black rock axa etc etc qui on remet la
légion d'honneur et qui veulent imposer
dicter leur loi par la force y compris
la force policière où toutes les
personnels légaux qu'ils auraient ils
auraient permis imposer par la force
contre la violente et violente ce pays
on violente son peuple à un moment donné
je pense que la seule esprit de
responsabilité que pourrait avoir
monsieur macron ci lui en reste encore
un minimum ce serait ycompris dans le
cadre de cette crise sanitaire de dire
eh bien on retire ce projet et on ouvre
de véritables négociations avec tous les
acteurs de ce pays
les partis politiques mais avant tout
les organisations syndicales
représentatives
on a refusé de discuter avec les
grévistes moi j'entends tout à l'heure
monsieur edouard philippe qui dit on a
fait les amendements etc etc
oui alors des amendements qui ont été
faits à la marge mais je note quand même
que y compris un certain nombre de gens
qui sont en lutte aujourd'hui et qu'on
écoute toujours pas comme les avocats
je parlais aussi des égoutiers dans
leurs projets on a encore les égoutiers
dont le régime spécial est supprimée et
qui vont avoir une retraite pour les
morts puisque leur espérance de vie est
de 58 ans est dans le projet partiront
toujours à 64 ans donc je pense que il
se passe quelque chose d'inadmissible le
gouvernement il nous fait la pédagogie
de la résignation
vous n'avez pas le choix laissez vous
faire on va imposer ça et on va réduire
arrêté ou ou je ne sais quoi écarter les
meneurs je pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui
que la population française ne ne sombre
pas dans la pédagogie de la résignation
et se rendre compte qu'elle est
l'héritière aussi de tous ses combats de
la résistance de 1936 de mai 68
j'entendais un collègue encore
aujourd'hui qui me faisait écouter
s'ils veulent pas qu'on manifeste dans
les rues pourquoi on ferait pas comme en
36 ans 68 et qu'on occupe aurait pas de
mon lieu de travail
dont acte c'est c'est en tout cas toutes
ces questions que le mouvement ouvrier
assez rapidement
auquel elle va devoir répondre il ya un
calendrier il ya déjà des mobilisations
qui sont prévues fin mars
mais là on voit qu'il ya des
manifestations spontanées je pense que
la question de la lutte est à nouveau
toujours à l'ordre du jour où nicolas
glières paradoxalement usage 249,3 on
vous entend et on redonne vue du coeur à
l'ouvragé
justement est ce qu'ils ont résisté à
cette réforme les retraites mais
clairement merci monsieur philippe merci
de nous mépriser merci de vous comporter
comme ça en fait vous nous aider
beaucoup à essayer de remobiliser les
gens qui parfois sont dégoûtés résigné
après 52 jours de grève
plus un rond eh ben on y retourne on y
retourne le corps enseignant est plus
touchée que tous par cette immonde
réforme les incarnent l'avait dit on va
y perdre énormément on réclame depuis
hyper longtemps c'est 40 %
d'augmentation sans contrepartie qu'on
mérite que tout le monde reconnaît
aujourd'hui on n'a toujours rien
les promesses faites par le gouvernement
et par monsieur blanc car ne sont pas
tenus ou balade on nous méprise s'est
passé de 10 milliards à 500 millions à
200 millions maintenant plus rien donc
effectivement dont appel dès lundi tous
les collègues être en grève à tous être
solidaires à une convergence des luttes
de nouveau parce qu on est tous
concernés
il faut arrêter de se regarder le
nombril il faut arrêter aussi que chaque
métier pense ne pas être touché et
estiment finalement ils gagnaient
laisser le voisin crever parce que c'est
vraiment ce qui se passe dans le pays
cet individualisme ne doit plus durer
faut qu'on se mobilisent ensemble pour
dire non à cet autoritarisme et il y a
également la conférence de financement
qui est en cours et qui n'est même pas
terminée donc on comprend mal également
se taille mais aujourd'hui avec ce
recours aux 49 3 alors que les
financements n'ont même pas été finalisé
en même temps on comprend même pas la
mise en débat de cette loi au parlement
alors que la conférence de financement
je rappelle à toutes fins utiles que la
conférence de financement a été décidé
sur la question du financement du régime
actuel et non pas du fameux régime
universel de retraite c'est à dire que
si nos propositions étaient entendus si
nos revendications ont été entendues
dans cette conférence de financement la
solution pour financer le régime de
retraite actuel
ces solutions
system canon beaucoup de choses la
question des cotisations la question de
l'égalité salariale hommes-femmes etc
etc
donc elles viennent en énormément de
choses on pourrait tout à fait sauvé et
ça on le dit depuis le début et même le
corps c'est dangereux dit depuis le
début on pourrait sauver le régime
actuel dans quel sens ça de vouloir
imposer par la force au bulldozer cette
nouvelle loi par que ce soit idéologique
le gouvernement démontre à nu une
nouvelle fois s'il en était besoin que
le prétexte de 15 petits milliards qui
seraient déficitaires en 2025 pour
saccager notre régime général ce
prétexte soleil est totalement
fallacieux et qu'en vérité c'est
absolument idéologique on veut imposer
une réforme au forceps qui frappe mais
c'est le montant des pensions augmenter
l'âge légal de durée du travail dans le
cadre d'un pays où il n'ya pas de plus
d'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
voire même via stagnation il risquait
même d'avoir régression tous les
analystes le disent et pour forcer les
français à aller vers des compagnies
privées comme blackrock
axa etc qui font déjà de publicité là
dessus on se demande surtout par rapport
à part par rapport à ça ce qu'ils on
pousse à vouloir aller aussi vite
et pour l'heure il veut pas laisser du
temps au temps scratch
qu'est ce que ça cache moi je
m'interroge pourquoi ils sont tous à
fond là dessus pourquoi ils sont obsédés
par cette contre réforme
pourquoi ils mettent toute leur énergie
là dedans cette rapidité cette vitesse
loria l'histoire des municipales où ils
vont se prendre une raclée c'est acté en
vaut presque sait pas devant politique
fiction voilà c'est ça mais disons
qu'ils sont partis pour en tout cas se
prendre une belle raclée ils ont
commencé à paris quand même
avec cette belle affaire qui a eu lieu
mais on ne sait pas où ils vont ils nous
cassent tous ils font n'importe quoi ils
montrent la population il énerve la
population ils mettent en danger sauf
que les dossiers va dire c'est une
première étape 149,3 ce n'est pas la fin
du débat vous acceptez c'est sûr mais
c'est intéressant
d'abord il n'y a pas eu de débat donc
déjà ya ni début ni fin il ya jamais eu
débat à aucun moment deux années de
concertation et non mais c'est ça mais
en fait la concertation méthode
gouvernement on la connaît c'est à dire
qu'on a été reçu des dizaines de fois
pour qu'à la finale ça soit toujours la
même chose c'est-à-dire vous pouvez dire
tout ce que vous voulez faire des grèves
faire des manifestations ça ne changera
pas notre problème c'est celui là il
changera pas donc ya pas eu de réelle
concertation
il ya eu même mise en scène de
négociation avec des organisations
syndicales non grévistes qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui fort marri puisqu'elle-même
dimna sais pas du tout ce qu'on avait
vendu nom n'était pas une régime par
points est finalement un c'est horrible
et tout ça machin 1 y compris la cfdt
aujourd'hui condamne le report au 49 3
et le projet tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
donc il n'y a jamais eu de débat déjà
mais une concertation et on ne va pas
dire sérieusement c'est vraiment une
pitrerie de plus un duo premier ministre
de dire que on encore en 49 3 c'est pas
le début de ces c'est pas la fin du
débat c'est le début d'un débat ça n'a
aucun sens on vote une loi on va faire
voter en votre bloquer une loi justement
pour interrompre le débat en accusant
comme ils l'ont fait 33 députés
d'opposition ce qui font leur travail
moi j'ai vu les images comme tout le
monde sur les chaînes parlementaires de
deux de la commission des lois on voyait
des députés d'opposition qui soit du
parti communiste ou autres qui font leur
travail avec un peu de zèle en nylon le
tout de même mais ce n'est pas la
première fois ces jeux et nomade c'est
clair que ce dont on parle on parle
quand même de ravager d'accord les
acquis sociaux du conseil national de la
résistance quand même un qui ont été
obtenus par le sang par le martyr de la
classe ouvrière dans ce pays on parle
pas de rien en vérité on parle d'attaqué
où devait lui disais oui c'est les
régimes spéciaux gnagna patin couffin
c'était faux seins c'est bien là les
retraites des 23 millions de salariés du
public comme du privé l'origine général
qui sont attaqués surtout ils sont prêts
ils sont près de 400 députés mais que
craint-il
ils ont même part de leurs propres
députés on se retrouve face à ana
parlement godillot servile ils ont été
capables de voter contre l'allongement
du congé pour deuil d'enfant tellement
ils sont petz tellement ils sont soumis
si vous êtes incapable bonnet villa
train on a terminé je remercie beaucoup
mathieu veulent reda et merci à vous et
nicolas glières d'être venu une sur ce
plateau pour nous parler de ce recours
aux 49 3 merci à vous